Thank You Marco huh thanks very much for
the organizers for the invitation and
the opportunity to be here thanks for
all of you for staying until the end of
the conference to discuss this topic and
it is really my pleasure to be here and
but I do not know this crowd very much
let me just give you a little bit of a
review what I what my background is I am
a professor and so this is a crowd that
is a very diverse crowd with a lot of
people from industry I'm an academia I'm
professor of mechanical and aerospace
engineering and in the in the u.s. I'm
also a member of the board of now focus
and I have been since 2015 I'm associate
editor of the associate editor in chief
of the Journal of open source software
jaws it's been mentioned before and jaws
is a project that is affiliated it's a
sponsored project of non focus and I've
been a champion of open source software
for research and education for many
years but in regards to the topic that I
wanted to share with you today in my
role as an academic as an educator as an
educator I have been I have taken the
opportunity to advance diversity through
both systemic activities and sometimes
eclectic minor actions that you have the
opportunity to do in in your spheres but
some of the public facing narratives
that reflect my contributions to
diversity include a collaboration with
Nvidia to promote women in GPU computing
that was we started that was done in
2014 we are a campaign that was called
women who CUDA and it was launched with
a blog post and Cyril activities that
comic that include a web page on the
Nvidia developers blog showcasing 30
women that were working with GPU
computing this a few years back and for
some years have been speaking against
male-dominated conferences in
engineering as well you can find some of
my writings about that topic or medium
here's a couple of examples and of
course lots of salty tweets the last
item here is in this slide is a long
essay I wrote last year to accompany the
key
luncheon keynote that I gave at Syfy and
today's talk is going to be an update
and a compliment to that let's remember
two years ago a Google engineer attended
a diversity program he had such an
adverse reaction to it then he proceeded
to write a 10-page manifesto that he
circulated or originally in internal
channels and among other things he said
that biological differences are the root
cause of women's under-representation in
technology this memo was made public in
this article and Gizmodo in August 2017
the engineer was so fired a Google CEO
said that parts of that memo violated
the code of content across the line a
dancing harmful gender stereotypes the
engineers soon of course became the hero
of conservative media and who banded in
his support he tried to sue Google in
January of 2018 for discrimination again
against white conservative men and the
National Labor Relations Board declared
a month later that the firing was legal
and so the the discriminatory portions
of the memo where legal basis for the
firing and so this was the end of that
but champions were quick to start
plucking supporting material for this
biological differences claim
I like this opinion piece that appeared
in The Globe and Mail the author here is
citing to support this idea of gender
differences a paper that does talk about
sex differences in the mammalian brain
which looked at the effects of hormonal
exposure on sex specific gene expression
changes on embryonic natural stem cells
in mice so quite a big jump there from
gene expression changes to biologists
improving
on interests don't you think of course
sex differences exist in the brain and
the physical trades and humans may be
psychological trades but do these
differences have anything to do with
interests this op-ed also cites several
other scientific studies that makes
equally big leaps of logic in each case
in my opinion and just after the Google
just a year after this Google memo
another big argument just detonated at
least on my circles online with this
article why women don't code by a
university lecturer at University
Washington in and the Pacific coast he
said that he believes women are less
likely to than men to want to major in
computer science and less likely to
pursue a career as a software engineer
and that this is what accounts for the
difference and the gender gap in
computer science degree programs and in
Silicon Valley companies so just don't
want to
he also contrasts in this article this
equality versus equity agenda and he
plans himself squarely on the Equality
idea rejecting this so-called oppression
narrative he puts it scary quotes on
that too and with the argument that the
women I talk to in Silicon Valley are
enjoying the experience as software
engineers and he then discount any
systematic exclusion from the text the
tech industry and he cites several
sources that supports his position and
then the author sighs for what is called
the free choice argument this free
choice explanation of low representation
of women in computer science he says we
have harvested the low-hanging fruit by
eliminating over discrimination and
revamping policies and so on but now
we're stuck we actually do not see any
improvements in the percentage of women
going to the computers in computer
science so he says that our community
must just face the fact the difficult
truth that
we're not likely to make anymore further
progress and and to attract women to
computer science and women can code but
they just don't want to we will never
reach gender parity he says he actually
says that his honest view is that the
steady-state level of women in computer
science is about 20% and we should just
accept that actually the comments to
these peas show that many folks do agree
with him so it's interesting I'm we may
have many people in the room that I
agree with that now the suggestion that
occupational gender segregation reflects
the choices of women often comes with
the premises that with the premise that
these there's some fundamental
biological differences that lead to
those choices now but if that were the
case then we would not see examples of
rapid desegregation of certain other
occupations for example like that
experienced in medicine so this is a
counter argument right the fraction of
medical school graduates who were women
rose from 16% in 1975 to 40% in 1995 so
just 20 years it does very rapid
desegregation today medicine has gender
parity women's interests in this
profession changed ah why well perhaps
the medical system itself changed to
accommodate women or maybe other reasons
i i'm sure these there may be studies or
if they are or not it's an interesting
research topic
the thing is people's interests and
choices are not innate
they have origins in culture and society
and the science of human development has
actually established that people don't
choose their interests or applications
freely experience economic opportunities
social expectations parental guidence
cultural pressures all those things
govern the choices that people make for
some
backing some scientific evidence that
demonstrates that culture of a learning
community is what determines interests
of people joining it here's an article
it's this report on a large-scale group
surveys of vocational interest and it's
by you know it's simply recording the
presence of interest in groups right
they not it records the presence but
this can easily easily be misunderstood
to suggest that if interest is not
present it cannot develop as an educator
and if there's any people that are
active educated in the room we do of
course believe that those interests can
be developed and we work actively to do
so with our students interest is a
psychological state interest can develop
and deepen you have experience you all
have experienced that in your life and
of course educators can support students
to develop that we believe otherwise our
job would be very depressing so a little
bit about occupational sex segregation
to give access context to this fewer
than one in five women worked for wages
at the turn of the 20th century notice
my emphasis on wages of course women
were working they were just not being
paid and it's still the case today in
many circumstances by 1940 20 / 7 27
percent of American women older than 16
were working for wages and that rose to
55 percent by 1986 according to census
data and the fear was 57% in 2017 quite
recently but women have always women and
men have always been segregated by
occupation at levels that remain stable
the segregation of it remained at stable
levels between 1900 and 1970s all
throughout the almost 20 the big part of
the 20th century there are ways that
economists can measure the level of
occupational sex segregation and it
start
to decrease in the 70s as women
integrated jobs that were previously
dominated by men so the percentage on
the other hand of women in the labor
force also increased from 38 to 43
percent in the decade between 1970 and
1980 and many many occupations during
that time saw disproportionate increases
in the representation of women variety
of sectors in the service sector
bartending bus drivers in the
administrative sector buyers and
accountants our public relations
professionals advertising specialists
many of these profession professions saw
lots of interest of proportion of women
notably computer operators which were
categorized as clerical occupations at
the time most employed women in the
1970s wearing clerical and service
positions semi-professional and
computing occupations were seen as an
opportunity for some technical context
but the sector was very vertically
segregated so there the systems people
were often men that data enter people
were often women there was segregations
within the computer professions in a way
also that effects wages so why so much
attention to computer science in this
conversation and one commenter in the
key yet article about why women don't
code Express an often argued
counter-argument counter example talking
about men being under represented in
many fields like Social Work education
psychology healthcare where's all the
hand wringing about how men are being
excluded from these professions so let's
be clear
occupational gender segregation is one
of the leading factors in the wage gap
therefore desegregating high paying high
demand occupations is a social justice
concern that is why there's so much
concern about computer science and not
so much hand-wringing about men being
under representing in the nursing
occupation additionally researchers in
these fields now recognize that there's
a form of sex discrimination that is
very hard to understand very hard to
decipher jobs predominantly filled by
men have higher wages than jobs filled
predominantly by women even when the
skill effort and education levels are
comparable this is the principle of
comparable wealth worth the principle of
comparable worth which deals with this
dilemma for example in 1975 nurses sued
the city of Denver Denver because their
wages were lower than tree trimmers and
sign painters certainly we cannot say
that the nursing professional requires
less skilled than trimming trees in
California California school employee
employees complained in 1985 about
librarians and teaching assistants are
mostly women being paid less than men
custodians and grounds keepers so this
is the principle of comparable worse
equally skilled or comparable education
yet many jobs failed predominantly by
women are paid less a separate compound
compounded factor of course is the
hiring discrimination against women
seeking to enter predominantly male
occupations even if some still may
disagree and I'm sure some in the room
do disagree I will state here and assert
with strength that moving towards gender
parity is the goal and it is rooted in
social justice concerns the question is
how to do it another aspect that is
important to mention is that evidence
has been mounting that companies with
more diverse workforces do perform
better financially this is a 2015 study
by McKinsey I will post my slides after
I finished and all my slides have links
active links so I'll post a PDF and you
can follow this links because I
recommend every company leader to read
this report it found
companies in top quartile for gender or
racial and ethnic diversity are 35% more
likely to have financial returns above
their respective national industry
medians and the estimate that they
estimate that for every 10% increase in
gender diversity in particular and in
the UK also in particular earnings in
the company rose by 3.5 percent so it
matters to the bottom line to be active
and correct these gaps so how to achieve
diversity is the question currently the
top intervention at tech companies is
implicit bias training so here's the
tweet from Brian Nozick who's a very
well-known psychologist and the director
of the center of open science who does
some research in this area and he to it
there's little evidence that such
trainings reduce implicit bias or that
even if they did that the change in
implicit bias addresses the outcomes of
interest for diversity and inclusion
they haven't really been studied very
well what the effectiveness of these
trainings are most trainings have not
been systematically evaluated the
available evidence suggests that they
can change awareness of bias that it
exists but it doesn't actually change
behavior finally training is really not
effective at addressing institutional
bias even if individuals chosen behavior
were changed we still have structural
structural barriers that persist
unconscious bias training can actually
backfire and have a diggety effects so
here is I recommend this article on how
not to suck at implicit bias training
this could be very useful because in
fact well the Google memo and all that
all that ensued with that was triggered
by an implicit bias training and
engineer being incensed by what happened
at that point so I will assume that it
was a very good one so for some advice I
recommend this medium post and for
example when in unconscious bias
training is made compulsory compulsory
without some proper messaging or
executive sponsorship some people feel
forced to attend and become resentful
and combative and then you have the
devil's advocate questions in the room
right then they spoil the session
cynicism is contagious and it all goes
down from there
number two many workshops actually fail
to educate people on the harmful effects
of unconscious biases so this leads to
normalization this idea where I guess we
all have biases and so it doesn't
provoke any meaningful change in
people's behavior just this says that
well we're kind of doomed we have-well
have this in our culture sometimes some
trainings will treat unconscious bias as
some scientific academic concept that is
detached from all of the oppressions
that people experienced whether it be
racism sexism of transphobia homophobia
Islamophobia etc that we experience in
our society and really in order to
create real change we need to understand
unconscious bias as a social justice
issue lack of practicable practical
actionable strategies also make these
trainings derail awareness alone is not
enough to create cultural change people
will just go back to their old habits
and too many organizations think that
conducting a one-time check the box and
conscious bias training will solve all
of their diversity and inclusion
problems and I just give some people a
sense of satisfaction but there's just
no silver bullet for creating lasting
behavior and cultural change the final
item mentioned in this beautiful article
is death by power
of course that can ruin anything any
presentation and the bottom line is that
a poorly done implicit bias training
will actually set your diversity and
inclusion efforts back most important
having skilled facilitators and when it
comes to contacting any type of
workshops having just read one article
and standing in the front and say I'm
going to lead a workshop is probably not
going to work what else can we do
so I've said the most by far a common
intervention is implicit bias implicit
bias trainings but what else quotas
scream emoji this is such a
misunderstood in intervention almost
always the response to the mere mention
of gender quotas or any kind of quota is
an argument about merit meritocracy we
can't lower the bar right for example in
2015
opinions contrary to Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau's declaration
that his cabinet would be made up
equally of men and women were vociferous
ly arguing the selection needs to be
based on merit let's be clear about this
merit is a fallacy education hiring
promotion pay elected officials
none of these are meritocratic professor
rainbow Murray I said it best in her
article on gender quotas in politics and
the blog of the London School of
Economics judgments on quality and merit
tend to be based on the status tend to
be based on a status quo and the
opponents of CODIS are implicitly
arguing for preserving the status quo
objective measures of merit simply don't
exist
what does exist is research evidence
that quotas raise quality contrary to
common wisdom here's a study and there
many more this study in Sweden looked at
zipper quotas in municipal politics
so we're parties alternated between men
and women on the ballot
that's a zipper quota right whenever you
apply this alternation of you can do it
in your I do it in my conference
technical committees make sure that
you're alternating and having good
balance through that deliberately this
are this study found that they measure
he raised the quality of the men who
were elected and the quality of the
group overall mediocre men were replaced
by more highly qualified women the anti
quota argument is that they are unfair
but what they are in reality is an
intervention to fix an already unfair
situation and they raise the overall
quality think about it if implicit bias
prevents us from making objective
assessments of the capabilities of the
work of others an equally qualified men
and women are perceived differently that
means that correcting gender bar and
bias raises the bar because we're
already measuring people differently
from the get-go and evidence supports
that in April 2017 the Atlantic ran our
long read with women in technology
recounting the endless attacks on their
professional standing the undermining of
their expertise the sexual advances at
conferences or off-site company events
constant chipping away at that sense of
belonging and expertise the article
narrates our report by the Center for
talent innovation found it found that
when women drop out of tech it is
usually not for family reasons but
workplace conditions a lack of access to
key create creative roles and a sense of
feeling stored in one's career those are
the main reasons why women leave and
another recent study a survey called the
elephant in the valley of 200 plus
singer women in tech found that 84
percent of them had been there already
in
Silicon Valley and in senior positions
right 84% have been told that they were
too aggressive
66% have 650 66% had felt excluded from
key networking opportunities for because
of their gender 90% had witnessed sexist
behavior at conferences and companies
off site of site events 88% had
experienced clients and colleagues
directing question to male peers that
should have been directed at them
60% had fended off unwanted sexual
advances and in most cases from a
superior of those women one-third said
that they feared for their personal
safety here's a story about data camp
many of you must have heard this view on
Twitter on the Twittersphere it's a big
deal because data camp is a big company
it has 3.9 million users over 190
countries and many many top business
customers and this happened recently at
a novel what it had been actually a long
time ago but it came it became public
recently at a week-long company event in
Portugal the CEO had too much to drink
one evening and groped an employee who
was dancing repeatedly even if she tried
to escape from him her feelings of
humiliation lingered for long after she
after the event and she quit after three
months she reported the incident to her
manager as she did so the reaction of
the manager is interesting he
immediately included justifications for
the CEO he's an ethical person maybe
there's some cultural differences
because he's Belgian
the CEO was actually did apologize
afterwards and reached out to her in a
private apology and later she learned
that the company did want to investigate
via a third party but as the incident
became public more than a year later
this third party was revealed to be an
early investor in the company so hardly
a natural person not to mention I'm
qualified to deal with such matters and
after the investigation concluded the
company's actions were to submit the CEO
to sensitivity training some career
coaching and a strong warning it also
would enforce sexual harassment training
for all its employees thereafter hire a
human resources officer and take some
steps to diversify its staff for the
victim window-dressing but she wanted to
move on at this point unfortunately she
was burdened with anxiety over running
into the CEO which led her to forego
career opportunities she also had
awkward encounters with her ex
colleagues who were friends and with no
public accountability this story started
to spread through informal channels as
they do and various employees and
affiliates started to raise concerns and
they were let down by the company's
responses but this community this is the
our community the data science community
and it turns out this community is very
sensitive to these issues so they
started to self-organize and they piece
together the story and a group form to
confront the company collectively the
company under pressure held a video call
with the community and ended up that
that vehicle ended up to be ended up
being a one-way webinar and the
community felt ever more frustrated so a
subgroup wrote a letter to the company
expressing their frustrations and sent
it with more than 100 signatories the
day after datacom posted posted on his
blog its first public responds with a
deluded account of the events and some
details
on behalf of the harasser and some
details that were you know made him look
better and this further incensed the
community at this point a lot of
indignations just split spread through
blog posts and tweets like here after
many months of collective negotiation
the negotiating the instructor community
the mail and the demanding transparency
they did nothing their public
announcement are not sufficient so data
camp instructor started to boycott their
own courses which of course damage their
income and then posted the content of
free on alternative platforms where
various data science organizations cut
ties with the company I've chosen
several tweets here to illustrate my
point and these there will be active
links oh yeah you can follow if your
interest the conversation that in
happens around this it really was
exploding for a few weeks on on Twitter
some renowned instructors publicized the
decision to stop developing courses with
them others stopped developing content
and just dropped out of their intentions
to do so the software and data carpentry
is a big organization of volunteer led
workshops in this field removed all
connections all recommendations to their
materials and issued an official
statement regarding this and at that
point it soon became known that there
were two data camp employees that had
raised alarms about the mishandling of
the harassment incident not long after
it happened and they had been swiftly
fired nominally for poor performance so
at this point they whole community is up
in arms the pressure mounted CEO had to
step down and he issued a public apology
while the company announced some new
investigation and the establishment of a
new instructor review board that would
bring in the community's input to the
company's leadership so that was the
status by April of this year many in the
community in the community it really can
tinu to mistrust will the CEO be brought
back well the investigation go anywhere
the company has a long way to go to
rebuild the trust of the community but
here's the thing
a whole communities action was needed to
right the wrongs of one harasser and one
company's relaxed us to make him
accountable this actually had this
effect because the community the our
community the data science community is
already very sensitive to this issues
and they just would not have it the
latest update from the interim CEO is
from May 28 I see that big jumper there
of silence they say that we have been
actively searching for and interviewing
candidates for a new and independent
member member of the Board of Directors
and also that we've been hard at work to
establish the instructor Advisory Board
has it happened yet and they said the
goal is to have the Advisory Board place
by midsummer it's midsummer but we don't
have more news so I think that there's
still quite a bit of mistrust produced
by this whole episode so here's a tweet
from bill body he said in the UK a chief
knowledge officer of the times of higher
education who has 25,000 followers on
Twitter so he tweeted okay what's the
most terrible behavior you have
witnessed in an academic conference he
was anticipating of course the
conference bingo of presenters going
over time asking questions that are more
of a comment or clipart on their
PowerPoint or a wall of text what he got
instead was an avalanche of tweet
replies recounting sexual harassment
which obviously surprised him
we have to hacked on this he says his
surprise and naivete were not
well-received I have to say replies
pointed out that it's men who need to
act on this because women have been
talking about these behaviors for years
at a great emotional cost by the way
some were more generous with him
explaining that abusive behavior is
normalized so you might not recognize
when you see it until you learn to
recognize this behavior so when you do
please call it out I mean and that's do
you what you what we've seen right in
this conference is an increasing
adoption of code of conduct and so how
does this address the issue some
commenters in this thread mentioned this
and this one this this interaction is
interesting first coat of condoms won't
necessarily stop sexual harassment but
it will state clearly that such things
are unacceptable that there are
boundaries and that there is redress do
people need a code of conduct to tell
them this somebody says well yes some
people do there's a certain group of men
who think that what they do couldn't
possibly be sick so harassment so we all
need to learn and that's why it's
important to have these conversations
and have the code of conduct all doubt
by the chair and actually over time as a
group we learn to behave better but why
is sexual assault and sexual harassment
so widespread in our society is it
inevitable some sort of animal behavior
that we can't avoid because of hormones
whatever it has it always been that way
let me tell you about the share of the
Cherokee people the Cherokee Nation
spoke a language that was devoid of
gender bias in their language okay
it was a matrilineal and matrilocal
Society of
at recontact times right before the
Europeans came where women were sexually
liberated they worked the land they
owned property they deliberated on
matters of war and peace they could
divorce their husbands when they wanted
to here's a quote from historian that
has written a couple of books about that
women had autonomy sexual freedom could
obtain divorce easily rarely experienced
rape or domestic violence worked as
producers farmers owned and their own
homes and fields possessed a cosmology
that contained female represent a
supernatural figures and had significant
political and economic power fact
Europeans were astonished to see that
share key women were the equals of men
politically economically theologically
they could not understand the
matrilineal social structure the most
important male relative of a cherokee
child was his mother's brother not his
father women owned houses that they
passed to their daughters women
participated actively in council
meetings in which decisions were made so
reflect on this women in the cherokee
nation did not experience rape or
domestic abuse or rarely experienced
theirs according to historical records
because Cherokee women were the true
equals of men this for the first time
hit it home for me when you hear that
the sexual abuse and harassment is a
power
it's a program but it's not about sex
it's about power you hear that a lot and
you sometimes don't really internalize
or understand when I read about the
Cherokee Nation it really hit it for me
I really understood how power changes
things
the history of Native women really
causes us to revise our assumptions
about the consequences of sexual
differences there's a direct historical
correlation between the US government's
greed for land and the erosion of
women's power within the tribes
the presence of the Europeans and the
how that translated in the US government
eroded power for women colonialism and
contact with the Europeans created
inequality between the sexes in and
those groups now in the u.s. a sexual
assault occurs every 92 seconds in the
case of rape of nine out of ten of the
woman's are female and eight percent of
rapes occur while the victim is at work
I have a friend who is a older lady who
is a dance professor and she told me
that she has a big class and one day
it's because it's a dance class there
were only a few men in their class and
one day they didn't show up so she had
only the women this was a time when I
think the trampled the election of [ __ ]
has just happened or something like that
and she said she had a conversation with
them and she asked them these are
undergraduates in a dance degree program
19 20 year olds what do you think is the
most important and relevant women's
issue for you for your generation they
deliberated and you know had a
conversation and then they determined
rape rape is the concern that is most
important for them as undergraduate
students in the university because every
weekend they go out and one of them
might experience it every weekend they
go out and they assign a friend to
actually look out for others or whatever
it is indeed very prominent in our
society but it doesn't have to be
I recommend this report by the National
Academies that addresses broader issues
of sexual harassment in academia and in
science fields in particular including
medicine it does have evidence and
data-driven conclusions and indicates
the pervasiveness of this problem and
one important conclusion is that they to
reduce or prevent harassment we need
system-wide change to the culture and
climate harassment after occurs in an
environment of generalized incivility
and disrespect it is less like
to occur when her organizational systems
and structures support diversity
inclusion and respect another conclusion
is that sexual harassment training can
be useful in improving knowledge of
policies and behaviors that might
constitute sexual harassment but it does
not have been it has not been
demonstrated to change people's
behaviors or beliefs similar to implicit
bias training I so I want to add that
often when we talk about people leaving
academia or technology fields people use
this pipeline analogy and there's a very
interesting piece that appeared in
Nature ecology and evolution that argued
that is impossible for the marginalized
groups to solve the diversity problem
themselves water can't fix the leaks in
the pipeline the entire community must
come together to confront biases and
women leaving the profession again this
is going to be an active link in my
slides it's a very interesting
discussion about this leaky pipeline
analogy but sometimes ignoring all the
confounded they are multiplicative
effects of all the barriers that women
face in particular here in academia and
we cannot ask women to fix these
problems because they are not in enough
positions of power we need the men in
leadership to seek the data on the
barriers faced by women and minority
groups to believe in the evidence and to
make commitments to work actively to
reduce these structural barriers
broadening the participation of
underrepresented people in stem
necessarily requires a widespread
willingness particularly by those in the
majority to acknowledge that bias exists
before transformation is possible I
recommend the book the better allies by
Karen Kaplan who a Caitlyn who had
25-year career building software in our
Adobe she's now a leadership coach and
she started the better
Alyx twitter handle for an example
currently
the pinned tweet has five things allies
can do to sponsor women and
underrepresented groups like speak their
name where they are and around share
their career goals with influences
recommend them for stretch assignments
invite them to high profile meetings
endorse them publicly do something in
the latest backlash to diversity
initiatives in tech a female manager
this time posted angrily in an internal
forum this just happened last April she
was responding to compensation
incentives for hiring staff for for
hiring staff on achieving diversity
roles and she just wouldn't have this
you so do so some fear and against the
merit-based culture and again brought
this idea that women are just less
likely to be interested in engineering
than men not because of any bias but
because they just think differently so
again this free choice and natural
differences argument meanwhile at MIT
Microsoft the fourth annual
comprehensive workforce demographic
reports talks about an increase in
female representation from twenty five
point five to twenty six point six
percent women in technical roles in
particularly increase from eighteen
point five percent to nineteen point
nine so at this rate parity can be
reached in about twenty two years I come
a calculated and there's similar
estimates for academia and other STEM
fields it just won't happen in time for
your or the next generation as we are
moving now the rate is too slow so we
need you all of you to make a commitment
to do something we need two or two ideas
we need men who are in leadership
positions and decide to become allies
and more women in leadership use your
position to hire women and promote women
so that they are in a leadership
position and use whatever position you
have to become an agent of change I know
I will but it's not enough so thank you
so much for your time and I'm available
to answer questions if the time permits
thank you
[Applause]
every module arena in talking thank you
for everything you do in the open space
let's take a question yeah if yeah it's
any question for Lorena over there
please not the devil's advocate in the
room a simple factual question what's
the worst behavior you've witnessed at
my data London this year I haven't
experienced any myself and that's good
news I have on the contrary observed
mention of the code of conduct by the
people but the organizers and the
leadership and that is very important
it's very important that if you are the
organizing organizer and you have
adopted a code of conduct to actually
state it in the beginning of the
conference and keep talking about it so
I thank you for your question the answer
is positive but I do have to say that
according to just the statistics of what
I've found out I know that in this room
right now they are there will be many of
you that are resistant of what I've
presented today that I find this goes
against the grain I know that you are in
the room somewhere I also know there
will be some women that have experienced
some serious situations and I asked for
your forgiveness if I've triggered some
painful thoughts I know that there are
women in the room that have had these
experiences but I think the take-home
message is that as a community starts
becoming aware together and working to
create a culture that is respectful and
as we've seen these things will be will
be decreasing and as we put more women
in positions of leadership as well and
really give them equal power we'll see
those things eventually fade hopefully
listen lady there that's a question okay
thank you
I was just wondering you were saying in
the medical profession there is now some
parity between women and men but is
there evidence that the sexual
harassment and incidence of that have
gone down I'm pretending no man in power
unfortunately no the National Academies
report that I mentioned does cite some
statistics about the experience their
women experiences sexual harassment and
and assault and as undergraduates and in
medical school and in the medical
profession fairly regularly fifty
percent I think is the order of
proportion of women that report that so
no I cannot explain I'm not I haven't
become educated enough to actually
explain why the medical profession
desegregated so rapidly but that hasn't
changed it this is this is a cultural
bigger cultural concern and hasn't
changed within that profession yeah I'm
happy to your keeper of the time
Thank You Lauren for speaking about this
right now lovely it's such a great way
to finish um yesterday at lunch we had
the diversity conversation and we were
speaking about so there's from the
female perspective there's like two
opposing sentiments about being given
something and knowing that you're
filling a quota so I love it I want a
diversity ticket I'm living my best life
yes so I'm I don't have any issues with
that but I do have some colleagues that
feel that if they win a diversity ticket
or if they get accepted and they know
that it's because they're feeling on
quota they feel really angry and upset
about that so how what would you say to
them to kind of conciliate that thank
you for that question that's a very
important issue it's true and it's both
so so they think both men and women will
react negatively to towards the idea of
coda because we have this irrational
believe that there is a there's a way to
measure measure merit and that
meritocracy is a thing that actually is
fair it's not fair and they're
understanding that first of all starts
people you know softening up a little
bit
quotas are just misinterpreted because
they're seen as a forceful move about
they have to be explained as a
correction of something that has gone
wrong the of course some people use the
Equality versus equity argument that is
also sometimes misunderstood but you
know like we have built access for
people with disabilities
you know and ease of entering and
exiting buildings and now we accept that
as a correction for include including
everyone that may have a physical
disability and these types of assertive
interventions against bias need to be
understood as a corrective measure and
we need to get educated reading the
little literature so we have those
arguments in there ready that the
studies demonstrate that is better for
the group overall to inject those
measures because everybody is going to
benefit from the fact that these
corrective measures actually improve the
quality of the group it's just
counterintuitive but the research is
there and it can be explained how that
operates so I think my recommendation is
let's get educated about it so that
we're not just reacting from our gut
feeling Karina's thank you so much for
your talk was amazing a lot of a lot of
companies that acknowledge these
problems are now optimizing our trying
to fight these problems by optimizing
for gender pay gap obviously it's a
metric that a lot of companies are also
forced to report and make public can you
like but it's also metric that is easy
to optimize sometimes that presumably
has flaws so what do you think about
that metric and theirs are there other
alternative metrics that can be more
useful metrics are always of course
conducive to gaming and some sort in
some way so you have to be careful about
you we need transparency so input it's
important to push towards transparency
and I think what we need to bring into
as an answer to that question is the
understanding that real change will only
occur when
we have when when the culture of the
company and of the group has switched to
so it's a collective action in the
meantime corrective actions to work but
always the goal should be that at the
end the light at the end of the tunnel
is a different culture like the
Cherokees had and working on that is the
hardest problem thank you so much for
staying here and sharing this topic with
me I know it's difficult and I know it's
uncomfortable and it is for me as well
but I think this this community is ready
to have the difficult conversations and
I thank you for giving me the
opportunity
[Applause]